We all started mixing colors when we were
very young, and we learned how to combine
different colors of paint to produce colors
that we wanted.
For light the rules are a little bit different.
If I shine a red light and a blue light, where
those two lights intersect I’m going to
have a sort of purply color.
Where the red light intersects a green light,
where the red and green lights mix, I’m
going to form the color yellow.
And where the green light and the blue light
overlap I’m going to form a color we might
call aqua.
Where all three colors overlap we have white.
If we consider these red, green and blue lights
as our primary light sources then by mixing
them in different combinations we can form
different colors.
Here we’ve looked at just a few simple combinations.
Let’s look at some more sophisticated combinations
of our red, green and blue primary colors.
This table shows how we can create a number
of named colors from certain amounts of the
red, green and blue primaries.
The numbers that are represented here are
our unsigned 8-bit integer numbers that we’ve
encountered previously, so they range between
0 and 255.
So, for instance, if we wanted to create the
color called cadmium red deep, we’d need
a red amount of 227.
So that’s a fair amount of red, given that
the maximum value is 255; only 23 of green
and 13 of blue.
So this is a color that’s made up dominantly
of red.
Let’s have a look at another color here
that’s perhaps a bit more balanced … let’s
look at hot pink.
It contains the maximum possible amount of
red, and a fair amount of green and a fair
amount of blue.
So this is a palette.
We can mix an arbitrary color from an arbitrary
amount of red, green and blue, and frequently
we’d like to give that color a human friendly
name.
We can demonstrate color name lookup using
the toolbox function colorname.
Let’s look up the definition of the color
maroon, and here we see the amount of red,
green and blue required to create the color
maroon.
These numbers here are what we call normalised
tri-stimulus values.
That is, they lie between 0 and 1.
So in this case, 0.4 in the red channel means
there’s 40% red, there’s only 2 % green,
and perhaps 28 % blue.
This function can perform the inverse function
as well.
For instance, if I had a color that had 0.1
of red, 0.2 of green and 0.3 of blue, it’s
a fairly dark color and a bit bluish.
It’s looking up and it’s telling me it’s
the color called midnight blue.
This function has got a database file that
contains eight to nine hundred different colors.
We could also use this mechanism to create
a color image, and to do that we need to pull
a little bit of a trick.
So I’m going to create a single pixel image.
Use the MATLAB function ones.
I’m going to create an image with one row
and one column, and three planes.
And it looks something like this.
To set the pixel, I’m going to set row 1,
column 1, and all planes to the color of maroon.
So there it is, I’ve created a single pixel
image, and if I display that now, I have my
single pixel image, a big solid block of maroon.
A very common way of visualising the way we
mix red, green and blue primaries is what
we call the color cube.
So imagine that we have a three dimensional
coordinate system.
Three axes: a red axis, a green axis and a
blue axis.
We’re going to introduce here the color
cube, and what we see here in this corner
is when we have the maximum amount of red
but no blue or no green, and we see, as you
would expect, red.
Up here, where we have the maximum amount
of blue but no red or no green, we have the
color blue.
This corner we have maximum green, no red,
no blue.
We see the color green.
There is a file in the toolbox that allows
us to display the color cube: the function
is called rgbcube.
And here it is.
Now this is a three dimensional structure
so we want to do a rotation with a mouse.
I’m going to move up here and select the
3d rotate button, and I grab it with my mouse
and I can rotate it.
So it is a three dimensional coordinate system,
and down here is the origin.
This is where the amounts of red, green and
blue are all 0.
So we can see this dark corner here, that’s
where there is 0 amount of red, green and
blue.
On the diagonally opposite corner we can see
where there is a maximum amount of red, green,
and blue, and that’s the white corner.
If we look at the different faces of this
cube, we can see that this face here is basically
looking at mixtures of red and blue.
This face here is looking at mixtures of blue
and green.
Of course, this is just the surface of the
cube.
If we were able to look inside the cube we
would find an infinite number of colors in
there as well; colors that we can’t see
from the outside.